the playing stage of the 2017 World
Championship is well underway and we've
already seen some pretty amazing place
from just the first few days but before
we get too deep into this year's event
we wanted to look back into world's
history and relive some of the best
plays from the past so after much debate
here are our picks for the top 10 plays
from world history kicking off our list
is the legendary Quadra kill by rapid
star on Karthus from the grand finals of
the 2012 World Championship when you see
those red lines coming down you know
exactly what about to happen
kaboo might try for any gauge here they
might choke up the guys there's gonna be
no play coming out for a bourbon isn't
enough toys and so you'll get drop these
down to an egg right now about 10
flowers didn't die from the damage
really coming from the groom's out at
the back just bleeding out at least idea
Oh
the assassin meta was all about sweet
1v1 and our number nine play is one of
the best from the 2014 World
Championship feast your eyes on the
dazzling moods of expecting and a days
to the death duel just finishes Trinity
force that is réaliser it's all about
fighting fights at mark going down what
is he gonna be enough to see this one to
be one again so the shadow was down in
DPS sees him taking cancel this Auto
Attack this you use rain all things from
pack a while da day was in his own
ultimate to avoid the second part of the
damage is that this flash plus he landed
his SPO right on death Mark Brock could
not have timed it any differently and
still Shibata number 8 on the list is
CLG primes double teleport back door
against SK gaming from the 2012 World
Championship
it's a classic CLG moment bold risky and
ever so rewarding
SKT came close to microwave this one so
CLG picking up a baster on that one now
we see boy boy teleporting they go into
the base
SK gaming's devastated looks spell out
just how shocking display was at the
time the Rox Tigers vs. SK Telecom t1
series from the 2016 World Championship
was one of the most intense in the
tournament's history and praised game
winning cross map arrow from Game two of
the set takes number seven on the list
and they even got the pickoff on Bank
Rush doesn't actually have to stop
pushing right now if they can delay the
recalls
[Applause]
overcoming in Christmas
how much work can be done
he's gonna tie up onto the turrets take
over the minions are gone and it's too
much SKT are here to defend the state
difficult freebie to pushing down to the
top along thousand boats back on towards
prey push back yet again
with Joe
screaming this is for kaboom cloud nines
game winning team fight against najin
white shield from the 2014 World
Championship comes in at number six
he will be coming around he's gonna be
proud to win this one but not only was
at the end to a dramatic and thrilling
game but it was also the deciding moment
of the kabuemon Alliance storyline which
led to one of the best sound bites and
leave history
in 2014 Matan imp for the best bot lane
in the world and in our number five play
they prove it with this absolutely
filthy to be three out play on HQ it's
going to show himself so it's gonna push
it out there it's already are they gonna
finish about one more also it's a little
early there is it don't aggressive he
gets the cured meats II can't eat a girl
to escape to say be amazing the matrix
dodged on the hook the perfect response
book the aggressive flash to close out
the kills and the lantern escape from
start to finish this is a masterclass if
you wanted any more proof that faker was
the best player in the world in 2013
look no further than our number four
play possible answer safety we'll be
able to escape their eastern United
coding triangle Cole's gonna knock 19
soared into the air
Brady's gonna folia wake up from the
side crescendo comes around SKT doing
great in this one now Kane gonna be the
target exhaust goes down but it won't
make a difference make special he's
gonna try and chase down faker yeah but
within front together torn down will ya
faker it's not
[Applause]
not only is his initiation onto prey
nearly flawless but does play in the
rest of the fighter is equally
spectacular Baker went right through
that fight all the way to the fact and
takes out prey at the very beginning
lightning rushing in at number three is
smeb's mind blowing kenan ultimate
against g2 esports from the 2016 World
Championship touching : wish you've
already been used a trick is running
away expected score town
but he needs me
the timing the positioning everything is
perfect what a play
[Applause]
saying sometimes one hit can make all
the difference and our number to play
from the 2014 World Championship
the wrinkles but the rectum and he's
going to get answer there I don't think
he's gonna cheer for the super minions
acrimony I saved up the damage full
adventure is down
to use these glass that he will and
folding down never complain to stop the
recall game and reckless is on the heels
recall living artillery he's going to
stop sign he has to one of the big
damage dealers go going is gonna make it
in back days there
here comes cyanide as well on the end
they're focused on the guardian angel
lasagnas ten cyanide slipping as this ol
dog will they be able to get it
Peck a up from the guardian angel pump
feel more heads well that's really
it was a heartbreaker from fnatic and a
moment of triumph for Jean but no matter
how you slice it you can't deny this is
a classic world moment every moment
every decision led to one of the closest
finishes of any game in world history
and for the top spot on the list could
it really be anything else other than
more from the SKT vs Rock Series in 2016
this fight in the top lane is decided on
a Razors Edge with split-second
decisions changing the outcome frankly
prayin peanuts to before to close off
the fight is the best we've ever seen
and well deserving of being the best
play in world's history does he find the
targets PETA has guardian angel baby he
plays frontline how much can they really
get
what else kitty kid it's gotta be play
get inside
baker's low how much more can they get
the struts come again it's too
dragging it back in
for peanuts
this game so there you have it those
were our picks for the best plays from
worlds which world championship was your
favorite and why we want to hear in the
comments section below thanks for
watching if you want more great content
be sure to hit that subscribe button
[Music]